Last time we looked at the candles of the sun.
Uh,
she's the Canterbury systematic.
And so,
uh,
and we discussed actually the variety of a philosophical,
strange,
philosophical,
theological and philosophical ideas that compose Dante circle of knowledge,
this,
this encyclopedic commpass or what's,
what's,
what's worth knowing.
Uh,
today we move into the heaven of Mars,
which is as you know,
uh,
the god of war,
that the name of the planet,
um,
and it's the heaven of music than tilling Mars and music because harmony out of
the belief that harmony is shut the meeting point or the result of a discordant
elements,
uh,
kind of Concordia at Concord in a tuning of hearts reached through this golden
tolerances.
The,
the,
uh,
the discordant elements can be different sounds.
It can be the passions within us up need,
tempering,
uh,
and so on.
Um,
this can,
is,
can be read profitably and you can do some of this on your own,
uh,
in conjunction or will allude to it in passing in conjunction with Canto,
for instance,
a 15 of health.
We are in 15,
16,
and 17 of paradise.
You could read it,
15,
with the encounter with a damp,
his own,
uh,
ancestor catch a weeder.
And so inevitably the reference to Brunetto Latini literally imposes itself on
us.
It's,
it compels us.
We are compelled to draw parallels and see differences between the two ancestors
who claim make different claims on this,
uh,
descendant,
intellectual and a dynastic descendant.
Who is Dante himself.
Uh,
you could also look at it from other many other points of view.
The,
the,
the point of view for instance,
of uh,
uh,
the other references to war and the kind of the crashing sounds throughout in
fair know that Dante producers,
if I had worked to give a title to my remarks today,
which I really don't because I think it's,
it's,
it's the variety of,
uh,
suggestions coming from,
from a Canto takes over,
uh,
the desire to,
to be,
to schematic and thematic.
But if I were to give a title today,
I think it's really very encompassing.
I would call it self and history.
These seem to be the most,
uh,
the strongest,
questions or Dante racists.
They are not high.
The terms of question,
self and history,
the relationship between the two may be new to us here,
but we certainly have been talking about the history before.
Uh,
the last time we did was in the discussion of Canto six of paradise where Dante
gives in the heaven of mercury.
Dante gives this overall,
uh,
history of,
of Rome,
uh,
its humble beginnings and then the,
the,
the construction of the empire and the crisis of the empire.
So that's really one.
Uh,
one thing that you,
one thing that,
you know,
the issue of self in itself is something we've been discussing ever since we
started with the Vita Nuova with the idea of a lyrical self over self who
removes himself as you recall.
That's what we mean by a lyrical self,
removes him oneself from the world of history,
the contingencies of time,
uh,
the,
the viscous realities of the city and takes shelter in the,
in the Chamber of his imagination,
uh,
in the world of,
of uh,
his ideas,
his dreams and memories.
And there he constructs his own self.
That was the point of the Vita Nuova.
When we begin reading the divine comedy,
I insisted on the autobiographical focus with which at least the divine comedy
begins.
This is his story.
This is his,
uh,
unique,
experience,
uh,
the pilgrims home Dante's own unique experience.
And that seems to have come to an end with the purgatorio 30.
When,
uh,
finally the normal of the self is sealed.
They should remember within mentioning of the name Dante,
uh,
then,
a new phase begins in Dante's construction,
which is more educational,
more speculative,
which is really the world or paradise.
But so we talk about self and history in a way that maybe Dante's never quite
coupled the two,
the two terms before he does.
So in Canto 15,
16,
and 17 of paradise,
this is really the double focus around which everything,
uh,
moves.
Let me give you,
I will,
I will give you a reading of the various details,
but let me tell you an idea of what I have in mind.
The first of all,
in the way of thinking about this issue,
I want to draw your attention to the presence of some mythic mythological
figures that Dante Dante is evoking.
And they're very different among themselves,
but their whole,
their whole,
it's a way of reflecting on Dante's own idea of selfhood and Dan,
his own relationship to an ancestor,
his own private history,
uh,
who in turn has had a very complex and for Dante,
no blink relationship to history.
He is a crusader.
He fought in the second crusade,
we 1149 and that the emperor Conrad,
he's proud of this belonging to the Crusader there has to fight as a crusader.
So she said a version of the relationship,
one hairs or things one has with history,
both catcher weeders and Dante's or relationship to his grandfather.
But let me tell you,
first of all,
this mythic figures and then we'll talk about them.
Dante is begin with Canto 15.
Uh,
I will just remarked in passing,
I will not,
I will leave it to you to do more diligently than we could do here at the
presence of music or metaphors,
which is not surprising in the heaven of the new music gracious will into which
this is the beginning of Canto 15.
Rightly breeding love always resolves itself as the cupidity into a new will
impose silence.
That's sweet liar.
This is the,
uh,
the soul as a tech becomes a kind of musical instrument,
a sweet life,
and still the sacred strings which are right hand of heaven.
Titans had relaxes and so on.
Uh,
and then this,
uh,
and the gym at one point,
this is line 20,
and the gym did not leave its ribbon,
but then across the radio strip has seemed fire behind the alabaster with such
affection.
Didn't cases shade reached out if may trust our greatest muse when it Elysium he
knew his son.
And then in Latin,
a quotation all sang with males or Super Infousa Grotzia they secret TB
[inaudible] Janow recruiter.
To whom has this privilege I've ever been given of having the gates of heaven
open to him twice.
That's,
that's,
that's see the light spoke to us.
So this is the first mythical reverence.
We are really,
we could just say,
well,
uh,
Dante of course at the very beginning of inferno makes a reference to Paul and
then he is disavowing any,
any,
uh,
strict connection with their memory.
You remember when he resists,
uh,
the core to this huge risky enterprise of going through hell that comes to him
from Virgil.
He says,
I'm not an ears.
I'm not poor.
Why should I do what you are calling me to perform a and they need yours is a
one who had visited hades to meet the shade of his father and Kaiser's now
recall there.
And of course,
uh,
Paul is the one who had been taken wrapped to the third heaven,
maybe a third mode of vision that allowed him to and kept quiet about it to see
God face to face,
but,
and cases,
uh,
the encounter between on cases and,
and,
and then ears here stands for result of relationship of an ears that in years
has with history and he is,
goes to hades in order to find out what the purposes are for his journey from
Troy toward an unknown land.
And he discovered this.
So it's a,
it's a way of unkindness discovers about he from his own father that the presage
the prophetic,
if you wish,
announcement of what it is for him to be part of history,
somehow a definition of sales.
That's what you'll find with an crisis engineered can be understood.
This,
that the sense that one hardest one belong in history and one belongs in history
as part of a providential pattern,
as the idea that this was a destined empire,
that he on Kaiser's head to found and the new history would start so that he
confirms his attachment to the dead father.
And yet he starts now as the,
uh,
point of a beginning for a new history.
So this is one way of understanding an epic,
the epic account and myth of one's own self belonging in the world of history.
This is mythical.
We move on and this really,
uh,
a bit,
sort of a reverse or of this,
uh,
I will come back into Qantas 16.
Dante gives a chronicle of the city of Florence.
This we'll say is for.
So,
uh,
he's,
he's making problematical to us.
The idea of what,
where are we to understand this itself?
Yeah.
This is not clear what we had to understand this herself in the,
in the,
in the Vita Nuova,
the self is this nexus of memories,
fantasies,
and the will to write poetry.
And in that sense,
the texts constitutes oneself interests of I am myself.
I'm the author of this text.
This becomes a point of reference and this is what I am.
The emergent portrait that I give of myself gives you an idea of who I am.
It doubles me,
it perpetuates me.
It's a poetic version of self,
but we don't know yet what,
what are we to take us.
So,
and crisis has a different understanding of himself.
I am who I am only because I belong to a larger pattern of history.
And this larger pattern of history is going to be me as a founder,
a founder of a,
of a new way of looking at the world,
the founder of,
uh,
of Rome.
And he gets the message from his own father and Canto 16 and I will not go into
this as I'm,
I'm,
I'm pursuing the theme of the mythic references.
Dante goes on,
uh,
really,
thinking about,
uh,
writing a chronicle is,
I will say no.
The city of Florence,
one for frauds is famous for its chroniclers that beginning in the middle of
agents in Deca.
So his history then the other problematical notion to be understood this,
the local events or is it to be understood the way I'm,
Kaiser's understands it as a myth,
uh,
that somehow his assault of a parodic dramatic value in which can regulate and
also,
uh,
a range are we can go on a ranging our lives according to the demands of that
myth.
Uh,
Dante would not answer this question correctly here,
uh,
but he does talk about all the,
the Florentine families and talks about them in an electronic manner.
This to say that all decade they are all finished and extinct.
So whatever value of his history of my head,
it's an a gigantic,
a commemoration of the past catcher.
Weda by the way,
is very elated at the idea that the son,
the grandson,
the sentence wants to find out about the past.
We move then into Qantas,
have a team where I think we find something about this whole issue about the
history and the self.
It begins in a,
in a,
in a peculiar manner.
Look at the beginning of canto 17.
The reference is really,
it's a long,
pretty fantastic,
it's a crystal can group,
very faster construction,
uh,
where you're a Turner along turn of a phrase to or for the pilgrim to describe
himself and himself in terms of fate on the famous figure as you know from the
classical myth who challenges a Paulo,
we saw him in the corresponding canto 17 of,
in fairness,
there was an illusion there to feta.
So a little touch of the symmetry of,
uh,
of cancers.
But that's really secondary at this point.
Look at what the,
the,
the scriptures like him who came to Clementa to be reassured about that,
which he had heard against themselves.
That is owning,
first of all,
it's a story that of the uncertainty of fair towns,
descendants,
uh,
that his father was a polo.
So he reassured himself him who still makes fathers wary with their sons.
Hmm.
This isn't the Canto Kutcher Weda what is the real relationship?
That's what that is asking that I have to this noble,
heroic figure,
Oh,
whom I'm proud.
But what is the actual relationship that joins me to them?
Such was,
I in such a was perceived to be both but Beatrice and by the Holy Land that had
changed its place for me before.
So he's happy that he seems to have to reaffirm,
uh,
this,
genealogical lines or history now becomes no longer a chronicle,
becomes now a genealogy can,
can we,
can we establish some certainties that we belong into a junior logical line?
Can that really account for us and for who we are?
So this is the issue,
uh,
that Dante is raising.
The failure of Phaeton is a tragic figure because it introduces the possibility
of an Dante says there's this,
that's what makes fathers and the area of their sons all the time.
Uh,
the idea that the Sun Juan's talk do the father wants to go beyond the fathers
and that the,
the,
the idea of tragic transgression that I can exist and therefore breach that line
of continuity between in the generations,
across the generations.
That's one over there.
The other one is much more tragic than before the canto 17,
as you know,
goes on discussing,
uh,
among other things.
The,
let me read the passage.
I think that this is much more sparingly.
There is to say,
uh,
without to my despair.
Um,
he says much better than anybody else can contingency.
This is line 36 contingency,
which does not extend beyond the volume of the material world is all depicted in
the turn of visually.
See,
this is another way,
still another way of understanding history,
that there is a contingency that the world of contingency contingency can be
subsumed within a larger transcendent paradigm.
Uh,
that seems to be the older of necessity.
That contingent world is linked to the volume where all things are present in
the terminal vision.
Yet that's not deriving,
as I said the anymore.
Then that's a ship that drops.
Is there some autonomy to contingency or things determined but the older of
necessity,
a downstream from the icing,
which is mirrored from thence as sweet harmony.
Last time I mentioned it,
musical language,
musical lexicon are bounds.
Here,
comes from an Oregon to the ear are,
comes to my site.
The time that is in store for the,
uh,
I,
I enjoy very much the implicit connection between time and music,
music becoming,
uh,
the,
the metaphor that makes,
uh,
makes a horrible time itself.
Oh,
uh,
prime is constitutive of music of course,
but it really makes it,
we,
it's an acoustic,
a translation of the silent Arrow of a,
of time.
And now this is the,
the other,
the third mythological reference and crisis,
the tragic story.
And Kaiser's who recognizes himself in the history and in the break,
in the continuity with his father.
And in the break with Troy,
uh,
from his father,
from Troy,
and the beginning of a new,
um,
let's say history fair town,
who turns against his father and Burns the heavens in doing so that they say
it's a famous metamorphoses of the origin of the Milky Way.
As you know,
the Milky Way was understood this,
the scorched,
the scorched heaven's a cosmological disaster,
that it was happening on account of,
uh,
the,
the rivalry between father and son.
And now the third is as he potters,
I say Polish the drop the story of the Phedre.
And I have to tell you this,
as he Polatis was driven from Athens on account of his rule and perfidious step
mother,
so much,
so much dao be driven from Florence.
This is special one ounces,
the exile as the fatality,
uh,
that is,
hovering over Dante and for which he has to prepare himself and exile where he
see what it implies.
Also sort of,
uh,
necessarily detachment from one's family,
one's country,
once hall,
all the possible lines that tend to join us and limit a limit us too.
So Dante is not quite in Kaiser's,
he's not out to,
uh,
establish an empire.
He's not like a,
uh,
the photon.
He doesn't,
not one to overdue at least,
uh,
literally the,
the father and now to see what to Swiss,
he pollatos as a politics driven from Athens on account of his cool and
perfidious stepmother phedre.
So must now be driven from Florence.
This is determined,
nay is already contrived because difference between determined and contrived and
the conjunction between the,
the older of eternal,
the terminal,
uh,
destinies and the contrivance,
the older oh contingency.
The maneuvers in Ferno maneuvers against,
uh,
against the pilgrim and will soon be accomplished by him who meditates it in the
place where Christ is bought and sold all day to blame in the Cuban crash or
follow the injured side is always,
but the vengeance shall be testimony to the truth that dispenses it.
Thou that's the announcement of the exile.
Thou shall leave everything loved most dearly.
And this is the shaft which the bowel of exiles shoots first.
That should prove how sold is the taste of another man's bread.
And how hard is the way up and down and other men's salary
and other men's,
uh,
stairs,
excuse me here.
There is a terrible mistake that saint Clair makes cause Dante's very carefully
aligned.
60.
He writes Margaret,
he writes,
Look Shanda,
it's sully Butler through scarlet,
which means going down and up and your translator.
My translator here has it the other way around because he's following your
logic,
which is all we would call it naturalistic logic.
You know,
you go to the palace of uh,
uh,
the Duke,
you go up,
you climb the stairs,
and then you come down off the,
you have been begging for some charity and then you have taken your more sort of
bread and you can go down.
But that's not what Dante says.
He says,
you first got down and then you go up and I hesitate to gloss it for you because
I think it's a little bit clear walk us kind of thing.
He needs that for him to go to go up,
which was really,
the dissent was lowering himself.
It's a little bit of a,
if you wish,
it would seem to be a dissenting to pry into humility,
but at the same time,
because he's reversing their natural odor,
the ordinary older of the action,
it's really an assenting to pride,
you know,
for me to go up here is,
it's like going down really,
I'm really degrading myself.
So,
but it's a very interesting line,
our acknowledgement of a sense of gratitude,
a sense of the spiritual ascent being,
uh,
inevitably first a descent into the self and then becoming in a sense.
So it's really,
yeah,
it turns the whole thing around,
uh,
was up and down in other men stairs and that would show way heaviest on the
shoulder is that wicked and senseless company with which thou shall fall into
that valley.
We shall become holy and grateful,
quite mad and furious against the,
so the,
the story of,
um,
of,
of Hippolytus is the story of their stepmother to go back to this idea of self,
uh,
it's the story of a step mother who is,
trying to seduce Hippolytus.
She's married to thesis,
uh,
and he runs away.
So the family becoming the destructive are the form of a destructive desires
within,
within that family forces him to go away or run away and dies.
And so you wonder why Dante,
uh,
is,
taking on and thinking of this tragic figure,
uh,
to compare himself to his exile had this potentially destructive and tragic
consequences that I happened to reporters.
At any rate,
we have three great images,
but which Dante's thinking about what is the self and how is the self to be
editor,
how does the self enter the world of history?
What examples did he give the can?
When we talk about any of the examples in the past,
I think that this is really the extraordinary,
uh,
the burden actually have a,
a text that I have been talking about in the past and it's the confessions of
Saint Augustan.
That text is about the question of how the self is related to history.
And Dante,
this agrees with Augusta.
Um,
for Ferguson,
the self is one that takes refuge,
the interiority of oneself and goes home.
Then,
uh,
at the time with the time of the conversion,
he can now rejoice in history and that is taught to them to clear the way of
entering history.
The other Ma Motif that you can have is the Motif of the other model you have is
the model of catcher reader who goes onto a self sacrifice of himself for the
benefit of a larger,
uh,
cause the cause of the Christian crusade in,
in,
uh,
in Jerusalem.
Um,
uh,
then there is the Aeneid that presents the I,
the idea of how the self enters the world of history.
It's political,
political activity and time to really,
uh,
sort of rejects all of them.
Uh,
this prophecy of exile with which can two 17 and gives a entirely different
twist to the cells relationship to history.
I inevitably I will belong in history.
There is no other way Dante says,
for the self to exist,
if not a,
by measuring oneself with the historical,
the pressures of historical realities.
But my own relationship to it,
it's not that we're over that of belonging is as,
as a new year's does into the world of history,
uh,
with feeling that I am,
the political world is going to be my way out of this maze.
It's not going to be the one like fatten and it's not going to be the one
represented by Hippocrates.
It's the exhilaration self,
an idea of a selfless inata this location from the world of research.
But then how are we to understand this,
this location?
Is this location a way of actually removing oneself altogether or just saying
that I'm out of place just saying that I'm out of time and somehow I have uh,
a relationship to history,
which is maybe polemical,
maybe,
uh,
arguably,
constructives and if so,
what is the way I think that we have to reread now the three cancers in some
details and,
and a,
and we come up with an answer.
You see them,
what is a,
what the issues here are,
let me start with Qantas 15 and see what Dante is specifically doing above and
beyond this,
um,
this overall pattern that he's putting forth in,
uh,
in Canto in the various candles.
You will,
you will see how encanto 15,
the,
um,
let's go back to Kansas City and you will see that the relationship to catch a
reader is also played the team or logically how often Dante's peak planning with
the metaphor wings in Italian.
It's Allie Allie Uri allegation.
That was the name,
the bearers of wings.
So the,
for instance,
line 52,
I speak of the uh,
thanks to her who cruddy with wings for the lofty flight.
Or a little later on,
Brian 70,
I turned to be a Beatrice and she heard before I spoken smell to be assigned
that made the wings grow my will and the later align 80 many,
many times that he stops after the third time.
Uh,
for this reason that it's playing to you are not equally feathered in the wings,
uh,
et cetera.
Uh,
the first thing that they do though with the exchange in the encounter with,
uh,
with,
with catcher Weda is focused on,
uh,
the city of Florence of old and the vocation of the Golden Age,
certain golden age where it kind of Utopian construction.
These are the lines.
Florence page two lines can to 15 lines 94 and 97 and following Florence within
her ancient circle from which she still takes tears and knowns.
These are the times of the day,
uh,
rung by the bills of the nearby church.
I bowed in peace,
so ba and chased.
She had no bracelet,
no Tiara nor embroidered gowns,
not girdle that should be seen more than there were no yet.
The daughter,
her birth put the father in fear for age undoubtedly not part from the you
measure on the one side and the other.
She had no houses,
empty or family.
No heads has Annapolis yet come there to show what could be done in the chamber.
This is a kind of infernal.
Um,
in from vocations you are really thinking of,
uh,
of clear powertrain Canto five.
You are thinking of Semiramis all those uh,
uh,
this,
this figures of uh,
uh,
the chaos of the appetites and are being recalled now in uh,
in this context nor yet.
They do chuck [inaudible] and so on and goes on talking about a catcher with his
own birth and then say,
let me focus a little bit on this,
the metaphors of,
uh,
the,
of Florence.
We should,
first of all,
the Florence is evoked within a closed circle of self sufficiency and called
within range circle.
The Circle,
the circularity of the city also implies it's kind of plenitude and the sort of
uh,
boundary.
Uh,
uh,
Dante does not have an idea of uh,
an expanding city.
He just,
he,
he enjoys the,
uh,
the,
and enlightened projects.
His idea of a city held within its own perimeter from which she still takes
tears and knows the language of a space in the language of time follows as if
everything could be measured and everything could be interrelated.
One is interrelated with the other.
And then this language of a foreign system as a Soba chased Pete and be so bold
in peace,
sober and chased,
implying that here at least he believes,
and it's lingering in him the memory of the famous idea of the so called body
politic that you have heard.
You know,
the,
the idea of the organic structure of the city is made of interdependent parts
just as space and time indicate the interdependent coordinates within which the
life of the city,
uh,
hair can be recalled.
And now,
and then this is followed in turn by a sequence of another for us all in the
negatives.
She had no bracelet,
no Tiara.
This is the city dressed like a woman.
Dante.
You know that one way of thinking about cosmetics is also to think of it.
They used to think of cosmetics as bad rhetoric,
uh,
perverse forms of seduction by means of which one could this figure the natural,
continents and beauty of,
uh,
of the,
the human form.
So Dante goes on in a sense,
by repeating this negatives,
literally this processing,
literally stripping that woman of all this super fluid is all this.
Uh,
uh,
this,
this complications and bring the city back to its home simplicity,
its original chastity and simplicity.
Let me just see this passage.
She had no TRRS note,
no embroidered gowns,
no girdle,
nor yet the daughter,
her birth,
but the father in fear as she had no houses empty.
Uh,
etc. So this is a,
uh,
this is the golden age is that's done to really believe in this myth of the
golden age.
Is it,
this is,
what do we call a,
there is a rhetorical,
rhetorical phrase for this sort of moving all the,
uh,
praising the by ground times.
It's the,
the so called tell that CEO that means your praise,
uh,
of the past,
which is more of a editorial strategy to denounce the imperfections of today.
It affect,
Dante has a radical he polemical view of the Utopian Spirit,
this idea of perfection,
that,
or the claim of a perfection,
uh,
that we,
we,
we pushed back into the past,
uh,
because it's no longer with us,
but we want to fantasize about.
And nonetheless,
he,
he's,
he's still PR.
He preserves it because you topia can become a kind of normative idea by means
of which we can alter the configuration of our own contingencies.
Our own history.
It made utopia store exists.
They may even be dangerous and people can claim a lot of interesting figures in
the history of ideas claim that utopias are,
are dangerous constructions because the four mental illusions about who we are,
and yet they become for Dante necessary.
Because we,
in the light of those ideas,
we can go on a altering what we perceive as the,
the,
the degradations of,
uh,
of,
of our own,
uh,
our own times.
Uh,
and of course this a myth of the golden age of Florence for the past,
uh,
literally,
disintegrates when seen in contrast with the reality of Dante's life as an
exile,
which is going to wait him in the,
in the future that is going to be so it's exile,
uh,
as,
as the realistic perspective of his being in history.
Uh,
and he makes a virtue of it.
It's not a suffering is we are going to see,
I'm just,
let me just continue with my thought.
The air,
he doesn't see that as a punishment.
It induces suffering,
but it becomes a virtual and we shall see why it becomes a virtual.
And in effect,
it will become a paradigm in which we can all recognize ourselves in Canto 16.
This myth of there's this also this golden age of tub of Florence with this
illusionary bode in,
in peace and lived in peace.
Uh,
whenever I hear the language of peace I do here,
I do overhear the echo of Jerusalem,
you know,
the,
the p the city of peace,
right?
Uh,
and that what makes it interesting.
So it's a typology of,
of,
uh,
another city golden of,
the,
the great,
uh,
time,
the golden age of the past is a kind of,
uh,
what the profits would always recall as,
the p the peace time of Jerusalem that they had.
They,
they,
the,
that the Jews themselves had lost and kept home,
ah,
commemorating in,
in the history.
What makes this conjunction a very strong is that to me is that in Canto 16,
uh,
Dante goes on,
um,
uh,
first of all talking about this at the chronicles,
what is a chronicle?
How does the chronicle change history?
The chronicle reduces,
it's,
uh,
it's that,
it's,
it's a mode of historiography,
different mold of historiography.
Uh,
the place where you can find these modalities of history is really bullied fuse,
who writes the consolation of philosophy,
uh,
at the center of which he figures the wheel of fortune.
Okay.
You remember the wheel of fortune?
This is blind folded.
A woman who,
uh,
revolves,
who rotates this wheel,
uh,
and which means that we were always on the shift.
The curve of the wheel will be up and down,
right?
So that a kind of historiography that derives from this boy Ethan insight is
that of writing the lives of families that ascent and descent and note the other
mode of historiography who we should be,
the historiography of the fall of empires,
for instance.
So the,
the what,
Augustine,
so there are two history of graphic models,
the one that you were available in the,
in the city of God where we really told about the fall of the Persian empire,
the fall of the Roman empire,
you know,
in a few pages kind of Gibbons sort of a group give them,
does it in a much more detailed way.
But this is really the idea.
On the other hand,
Nantha goes to another historical graphic model,
which is that of chronicle,
the idea that history is reducible to the events,
the local events and circumstances of one's own life.
He recalls all the families to the joy of the grandfather who was,
you know,
you're going to understand the pressure of memory,
the,
I know he shuttles back and forth between in memory,
uh,
between one,
one item and the other recording everything.
And Dante soon discovers that he does not quite belong,
that that kind of history does not really account for who he is and who he wants
to be above all.
And that somehow his definition of self will depend on a certain idea of the
future.
And nor of the past I am,
I am trying to go back and to this idea of who their selfies and what his
history and how are we to understand history,
but here to continue with it.
The notion of Jerusalem,
which I have not,
which I bragged a little bit and gave you a little digression on history.
Uh,
non goes home talking about a language,
uh,
turn to cancer.
16 line 50 please.
Where he again talks about all about Florence Mar or who were there the time
between March and the baptist.
Let me theology of Florence.
Um,
cities,
a neuron or you recount stories of families,
you have to recount stories of the predominant,
the sovereignty of mythologies that control our own self understanding.
We will tend to understand ourselves in the light of,
of presiding mid.
So imaginative mates above us.
So there's Mars,
but was the god of Florence before the baptist.
John the Baptist replaced him.
So this is the account.
But then the,
the shifting mythology of the city Marsa map,
this able to bear arms was a fifth of the number.
Now living that this is really an accounting I chronic worse position and
accounting of Florentine local history.
They say the [inaudible] but the citizenship which is now mixed with
championship towel doing Filene and so on.
Uh,
that language of mixer,
which later becomes confusion.
And Dante,
we'll call it the confusion when he has to give a diagnosis at the top of page a
line 67 Dan has to give.
It goes into a diagnosis of the crisis of the city,
the mixture of peoples where it was ever the beginning of the city's eels is
fooled in access is over the bodies.
Once again,
the connection between,
he's talking about the malaise of the city by the connection between body in
cities,
cities grow and decay and get sick because of what he calls the confusion.
First of all,
he called the mixture and confuse [inaudible] is the other name for Babylon.
When you had to,
etymology dies Babylon into the romance languages and,
and and then in Italian or in English,
it's confusion.
So that the two myths of the city that Dante has in mind,
it's Jerusalem or for Florence and then Babylon for Florence of today,
two minutes of the cities of the,
the two cities are not antithetical.
They are both possible.
We see within the same body politic,
okay,
uh,
Florence can look like Jerusalem or it can look like Babylon according to the
way the,
the,
the moral life of the city is,
uh,
lived out.
So this is something that Dante will preserve it,
but it really,
it really implies that that the uh,
the city,
the political world is one which one has to shape all the time that you cannot,
there is no definite metaphor or emblem to define a particular city.
A city can change.
It's very identity.
It can become like can be like a Jerusalem as it was in the old or it can be
like Babylon.
Now the city involves us.
We are involved in the city's history in the way of making it according to our
own,
our aspirations,
our own ideas.
We share in the shaping of construction of the city.
This is not longer.
The,
the perspective of the chronic ward is the perspective dentists the port.
So it's a critique of the net secrecy of the chronic was view of what history,
uh,
could be.
And now we go back to Ah,
canto,
ah,
17 where once again,
and I'm going to,
uh,
I will not go up.
Well,
you remember it comes to fat on and the rivalry with the father and Dante
saying,
uh,
if I don't belong to the city and I,
and city and families go on decaying and disappearing,
what is the true relationship that I have to this main who actually is directing
me and unveiling for me or that which the future,
uh,
that don't have to expect from the future.
So these are the kinds of questions that he's very carefully,
uh,
raising.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we go back to the,
the famous,
uh,
description of,
of the,
uh,
the Dante's exile where,
we did describe,
yeah.
That she'll leave everything loved most dearly lines.
Uh,
uh,
55,
loved most dearly.
And this is a shaft which the bow,
the bow of exile shoot first.
Oh,
the condition,
the harshness of exile could not be crystallized in,
in,
uh,
sharpest terms.
Uh,
the severance,
the separation of self from family as apparently as a punishment.
At this point,
Dan should prove high salt is the taste of another man's bread.
There are those who think that he had Dante's finding a little bit of,
uh,
mildly comic relief in remembering the fact that in Florence they do use sold in
their bread.
But anywhere else around six year we have a,
uh,
a frequent flyer to Italy who remember,
who knows very well this little history.
But I don't think that it's hold that comical.
I think it's,
uh,
it's a,
it's the bread.
It's,
it's a no Sacramento of foods,
right?
That he's,
uh,
he's talking about.
Uh,
and then we shall see how he picks up the idea of the bread in a moment.
Um,
it's just not a metaphor there.
They'll show and how hard is the way down and up.
And other main stairs.
And that would show a way heaviest on the shoulder is the Wicklow.
We could incest senseless company,
the word picks up the metaphor of the bread because company means and that which
simply means the sharing of bread with,
uh,
with others.
So bread truly Sacramento in the sensor in joints and,
and brings about the unity of the body of the body politic were Dante saying is
that it's a reflection on his own life at little diff reflection his whole life.
He went into exile as you know,
in the year 1302.
And for a number of years he went home at least two,
three years plotting along the side of his other fellow exiles,
the return to Florence and the destruction of the enemies who had banished proud
of revenge in order to restore what they saw as justice Dante very quickly.
And the stood that this was the way to absolute destruction.
So he,
he just from then known moves like a shabby derelict to y'all.
He represents himself limping at the beginning of inferno.
And that is really the,
the uh,
the way we can,
we are asked by him to imagine him as he goes when he's talking about exile,
we are not talking about living in some kind of a isolated splendor and some
code or other.
It literally means going from place to place,
begging.
Uh,
so this is punishment for him and yet,
and yet,
uh,
let's see what happens with which I'll show forward into that valley,
which shall become holding grateful,
quite mad and furious against the he is an exile to the exiles.
Both the welds [inaudible] this trust them and take their distance from him.
But before long they not,
thou shall have the brows red for this of their brutish folly they're doing,
she'll give proof.
So it shall be to thy honor,
to have made a party by myself.
What an extraordinary line to be absolutely on your own at party to myself.
This should make you,
should give you some perplexity to say the least because you may remember that
the divine comedy begins with the representation of the so called neutral in
angels.
And those neutral angels were angels who wanted to be neither with God,
no against God,
but they want to be by themselves.
You remember how I pointed that out to you for that this was the most despicable
of conditions and choices though it seems to be non choice one is really
choosing any way,
even when we're not choosing,
we're choosing and he is.
He was separating.
The twin is despicable not to take sides to sit on the fence and now he seems to
attribute that very conditioned to himself.
But to you it will be to your honor to be a part to that self and no,
we did not read it.
But you know with those of you who were so taken with a poem,
you can go and read Canto of Paradise.
What?
That they will ask one question,
he will he to the soul that he meets,
he says,
is it right for a man in,
in,
in the,
in the city to be a citizen?
Yes.
He says,
and I don't even want to ask why it's so clear that that has not,
it needs no justification.
No explanation.
You have to be part of the,
the belong to the world where you are.
And yet now he takes the other side.
He has to be by himself.
What does it mean to be by himself?
Is that a kind of neutrality he's imagining?
Is that it's really the condition of exile?
I think that he's really describing the destitution,
the loneliness,
the severance of the self from others.
But even that can become a condition that triggers a new form of relationship
with the exile is still part of the community.
And let's see how he is thinking of,
uh,
of this want to,
um,
uh,
so,
or this is this,
this is now the specific prophecy of what's in store for the exile.
And I think it retrieves that's this in this sense.
I mean that Dante's bringing about the transformation of the d of exile from
what seemed to be a punishment into a virtual,
there is such a thing as a virtual of exile.
The language with Dante presents the world to come for him.
The,
the future.
This is his future.
It's not the past history.
Then it's understood as a Volvo futurity.
We are here oriented to the future.
The only real time that we have,
we don't have,
we don't have it yet,
but we can.
It's the type of one's projects.
It's the time in which one can really define oneself.
I'm not really my past.
So that is,
I have some contact with a past my memories and my memories can tell you me
where I'm going.
But then a catastrophe occurs.
The need to sever yourself from anything that you know and you love most dearly.
Family,
city loyalties,
your habits,
your bread,
all of this details are here,
are given.
And at least what he finds the first day,
first refuge in,
in,
um,
uh,
as of those of you who read,
it's a,
it's an interesting metaphor in medieval literature.
Those of you who read Chaucer is everyone here reads,
chosen the,
the,
the Canterbury Tales.
So,
uh,
of course,
it's a story of pilgrims and the in becomes the station,
the temporary dwelling of people who are on the road and always moving.
It's really one of the most welcome images in the medieval imagination.
The in the provisional comforts for the night that the in office anyway,
the first refuge in,
in that shall find in the courtesy of the great lawn barred.
This is uh,
the,
the gentlemen of Verona,
the one gentleman of Verona whole houses him and hosted him for a while who
bears on the ladder,
the sacred bird.
And he will hold z in so gracious regard there of doing an asking between you
two.
That shall be first,
which the others come after with him.
There shall see one where his birth so took the impress of this mighty star.
His deeds would be renowned that people have not yet taken note of him because
of his youth for this wheels of circled about him only nine years,
but before the gas gone deceives the Nobel Harry Sparks of this hair.
Heroism shall appear in this,
in this regard with Bert,
both of wealth and toil.
And this munificence shall yet be known so that his enemies cannot keep silent.
I part it looked to him and to this is benefits through him.
There shall be altered fortunate for many rich changing state with beggars and
none shall bear this written in my mind about him and tell it,
and he told things and she'll be incredible to witness them.
Then he added son.
This other glosses on what I was told,
the infernal 15,
of course,
remember we're Brunette who says
this is the profits of your future exile,
but it will be glossed for you,
um,
by somebody else.
It doesn't even mention it.
Dante goes on thinking that it's going to be Beatrice.
It turns out to be his,
his father,
his ancestor,
a,
these are the snares that are hidden behind the few evolving years.
Yet I would not have the envious of their fellow citizens for their life.
Chafat outlast the punishment or the perfect is,
uh,
the exile can turn into a virtual and the language that accompanies this
prediction is the language of the ethics of exile that they exiled,
brings about and needs in order to,
to,
uh,
be bearable and tolerable.
The hospitality and these how the great,
the courtesy,
the hospitality,
the language of gratitude,
the giving.
So it's a new ethics is going to be described in from the perspective of this
exhilaration,
uh,
experience of,
of Dante.
Then Dante concludes,
which I think,
uh,
I think it seals what,
what I have been saying.
And uh,
uh,
I see,
well,
my father,
this is line one 13 and following a one,
I'm sorry,
one 10.
And following us.
He,
well,
my father,
how time spurs towards me.
The deal two deal me such a blow as falls most heavily on him or his most
heedless it is well,
therefore that I arm me with foresight.
That's another virtual of exam.
The word translates.
Uh,
of course,
uh,
prudence.
Prudence is the human counterpart of Providence.
It's,
it says,
hey mythology,
a scene in advance,
trying to not predict that for a store.
The arrows and things that come our way.
Uh,
so that if the deal,
this place is taken from me,
I may not lose to others.
The others by my songs,
songs down to the world of endless bitterness and on the mountain from who's
fair summit,
the eyes of my lady lifted me.
And after through the heavens from light to light,
I have learned that which if I tell again with taste for many of bitter herbs,
and if I am a timid friend to truth,
I feel to lose my life among those who will,
uh,
call this times ancient,
the light within which was smiling,
the treasure and another reference to Brunetto who wrote the treasure.
Of course,
I had found their first became a blues,
like a Golden Mirror in the sand.
They replied,
conscience,
dark with its whole note.
Another shame will indeed feel that words to be harsh,
but nonetheless put away every false hood and make plain all the vision and then
let them scratch.
What is the itch for?
If they voices grievous at first taste,
it will afterwards leave vital nourishment when it is digested.
This cry of Diane shall do as does the wind,
which strikes most on the highest summit.
And that is no small ground of honor for that reason have been shown to lean
this wheels on the mountain and in the waffle valley on this holes that are
known to fame.
Because the mind of one who hears,
we're not Paul's of fix.
It's faith for an example that has its root unknown or hidden or for other proof
there's not manifest.
Um,
what,
what he hears and the decision that Dante will take is a palliative at least,
or a remedy to his exile is writing the writing of the porn becomes the act by
which he is an exhilaration,
uh,
as an exile can go on.
And in his,
this location is Arthur.
This location from the city,
from family,
from his habits can go on actually relating himself to the world.
Writing the work is that way in which their self and entries history and can
shape history.
It's not any ears.
It's not fair it on,
it's not going to be,
uh,
the he Polatis.
It's not even touch a weeders on account of his own grandiloquent connection
with the world of history.
The way in which this Dante self and this history is through this idea of,
of poet overwriting.
There is now also described in terms of food.
As you can see here,
first of all with the bitter herbs and now the voices gives their first taste.
It will afterwards live vital nourishment when it is digested,
uh,
et cetera.
Uh,
words,
words.
First of all,
let me just clear the air here.
No one,
no one of you has this misconceptions about poetic language that somehow it's a,
some sort of faint symbol divorced from reality that goes beyond this idea of
the relationship of language to representation.
That was the problem with a chronic roles and they gave fairly faithful accounts
and he can give fairly faithful account that,
that that's the mode of a certain historiography.
What Nancy is saying is that words are things in themselves,
that word words are food that change and being things they have a kind of
solidity and the result of truth value in and of themselves.
This is really the biblical language that resurfaces,
you know,
son of man,
if the book you remember these lines from say [inaudible],
this is exactly the kind of language that is returning here and which don't have
bands sort of language to define himself in relationship to his future project
of writing the poem.
And that project of writing the poem is his way of establishing his place
literally in which is a utopian place in history.
I say Utopian because it doesn't have to be understood in any local sense.
And also I do not belong.
I don't belong to the city,
only occupy a particular place in the city.
Uh,
it is the act of writing poetry.
That's really what matters.
What I'm referring to is also eh,
and here I am a sort of correction,
but in mild correction of the classical idea which,
which is also medieval has survives in medieval times.
The idea that the self is decided,
the value of the self is decided by the place one occupies within the corner,
me of the city.
Dante says,
that's not the way it works.
I am the project of writing my poetry anthropoid which is written in exile and
therefore it's a poetry of exile.
I can re enter the world of history,
ah,
the [inaudible] accusing history and talking as a man who has been touched by
the vision of what justice of today.
So this is really the remarks that I think I can make about this cantos 15,
16 and 17.
And I work some welcome questions for you.
Have any,
I'm sure,
sure you do.
Yes.
And see some biblical references within the lines between 700 mentioned star
burst in,
this is a line 17.
The question is,
uh,
would she be right in seeing a biblical antecedents context for the lines with
that go from line 17.
You say the first refuge and in no,
I think the shall find in the courtesy of the Great Lombard,
uh,
they may be a Christological or a crystal mimetic language behind this sort of,
references,
uh,
the end that would be even more,
um,
it would be true or even would be more made,
more compelling,
um,
uh,
in,
in light of a catch up with his own self representation.
Uh,
in Christological terms,
both in Canto 15 and uh,
uh,
in cancer 16 actually he talks to himself as if we're a boolean philosopher.
Dante uses the same,
the same phrase about the death of [inaudible] used for [inaudible] in Paradiso,
Yvette Nida,
[inaudible] Patrick that he had used for breeders.
But the language is a Christological language.
The,
the,
the only difference is that,
uh,
if there is a Christological resonance here,
it very quickly fades because Dante is really discussing himself as an exile
with this.
And I'm here.
The understands exile is that real condition of human,
of,
of himself,
but also of human beings.
I would go on.
So,
so far as to say in order to connect your theological perspective and,
but we're have been saying about herself in history.
Is that
okay?
Exile is also the root or re once religious consciousness.
We have a those,
those of us who have a religious consciousness,
I think we all do a,
just as we have an aesthetic sense,
we all do,
uh,
that religious consciousness come to all of us out of the sense or the feeling
even better,
better than the sense the feeling that we are not where we should be,
that uh,
that we are somehow,
I don't know where we should be both in terms of time and all in terms of space
that we are this located and this exile is exhilarating imagination than shapes
are also the theological,
the theological language of Dante and accounts for uh,
his,
uh,
persuasion.
That exile defines the human condition and of just,
it's not just an empirical,
it is empirical experience.
I say it,
it relates to him,
but he understands that it's really,
we are all in engaged in this kind of,
we talk about this later,
probably by the way,
I am forcing my hand because the text does not really allow me to do that.
That when he discusses hope,
uh,
the most extraordinary of,
of of all virtues,
the most deceptive maybe of all virtues and they're healings,
hope and exile in a very clear way.
And uh,
our reserve,
that is a surprise for whatever next week or,
yeah,
next week
please.
You mentioned the confessions earlier and talking about the different
conceptions of how the self relates to the city.
And you said Dante didn't agree with,
I guess I didn't catch everything that you were saying about Augustine's view of
the self.
Uh,
the question is about,
I was discussing modalities of,
uh,
this,
relationship between the self and history at the beginning of my remarks.
And one of them obviously was a,
I mentioned,
let me just give a little resume of this.
Uh,
mentioned the Catcher Weda himself,
who has a kind of special understanding of history and that defines him.
His sub is taking part in the Crusades.
The other one is,
uh,
with which Dante begins is in ears,
who is a modal for Augustan,
as you know.
So I'm answering your question now.
Uh,
the confessions of Augustan are constructed as nothing less than,
what do we call,
what I call the [inaudible] of the heart.
They say,
he goes here,
he goes from Carthage.
He has his Dido's.
She remember when he leaves Carthage to go to Rome and the died off.
It doesn't get,
he,
that's just abandoned them,
but he describes them as they hold on to his Helgam and et cetera.
Then he goes to Rome.
So it's really a pattern on an epic,
on the,
on the Virginia and epic of the,
the,
uh,
the Aeneid.
But cast it is very different for many years.
He doesn't go to Rome to found an empire.
He's a professor of rhetoric.
He teaches,
he's a teacher and professor of rhetoric.
And he comes to understand himself actually,
uh,
the great moment,
the great revelation to for him.
There are two moments of great revolution to him,
uh,
which we never really never talked about.
The one which he has,
well,
he's in Austria.
It's a little town on the,
on the beach by the sea outside of Rome.
And this is this moderate the window.
And they share and it kind of mystical vision.
He describes this ecstasy that they have or they look outside and then she's
about to die.
She will have,
but that is a decisive moment in clearly in his life and his understanding of
himself.
Uh,
and,
and the other one comes in the garden in Milan when he hears voices that tell
him to too.
He understands in his own way.
So it's a,
it's an idea of herself,
which is,
uh,
which,
which understands herself as a,
a death of the old man and the birth of a new man.
This is the,
the old Adam and the new Adam.
The,
the,
the Christian idea of conversion.
Same Poles.
So impulse command,
you have to let the old men die.
So the new law,
the new men can come into being.
That's the understanding of the self.
Now,
Dante,
of course,
when I say he doesn't agree with,
of course his Nordonia,
he'd say,
didn't say that he's not tall.
He did say that there are those who say,
well his ironic,
I don't think,
I don't see where the irony is.
He's not in here.
So this is not Paul.
He uses them to,
to,
to relate,
to coordinate himself to them.
And now he's using a number of other mythical figures.
What is one's whole relationship to genealogy?
What is one's hold Russia relationship tool?
The,
the,
the chronicles where it's the only relationship to mythical empires in the
center.
What I'm saying,
the idea of self that he's going to have,
it's not really Augustans is that of the man,
first of all,
who can belong to the history of,
of,
of the world by writing,
uh,
writing the poem and,
and he lives and he understands the,
the fundamental quality of the experience of human beings.
That's not Augusta.
So that's what I meant.
No disrespect for Augustan only different,
a different experience.
Oh,
um,
yeah.
I'm still thinking about the brief reference to the Crusades that Cacciaguida
makes at the end of the 15th Canto and the presence of sectarian violence.
And I wonder if that is done to,
has some idea about that that connects to his idea of the empire as staving off
the political violence of civil war.
What were done to suggest,
as we saw thought Saint Francis last week,
who taught,
who spoke peacefully with us?
This is an extraordinary question.
Uh,
the question is,
by the way,
uh,
the,
how do I explain,
uh,
catch a,
does reference to the crusade very brief referenced crusade and how does that
connect with what we have told been talking about sectarian violence.
So in the can't have Dominic for instance,
in Canto 12,
and uh,
with a Dante is using this as a ploy to explain just the way he does with the,
the violence within the city to justify the necessity of the empire,
which he does or,
uh,
is this,
does he really have an idea of uh,
uh,
the peaceful language of Francis Accurate?
If you ask a lot of questions and they're really,
really good,
really,
really a impressive after all,
she's an Italian major.
What did you expect?
She has she better impressing me or no,
you did.
You did the,
okay,
we'll talk more about Dante's preparing can talk.
Oh seven,
18,
19 and 20.
It's really about,
starts with what is a heroic life and how are we to understand the heroic life.
So,
and then he said reference they all sorts of crusades and the question of the
Crusades,
the relationship of a justice and Christian ideas of justice tool,
Muslims and Hindus will come to the forefront there.
So I really asked you to wait for that for next time because however I can
answer one question immediately.
Uh,
which is really implied by what you were saying more than the US directly.
Yes.
Dan P is a piece poet.
I would say that with full confidence low,
we know a Dante,
so polemical kicks,
shades is angry,
uh,
fights and this always competing visions really in relation to the tradition and
others.
But he's fundamentally,
you have to establish,
it would say differences,
not really renounce your differences,
but actually make differences.
The orchestration,
the musical orchestration is going on in cantos 15,
16 and 17.
This is the heaven of music.
This discordance discourses are part of it over over a sovereign and
transcendence order.
But he's a piece of port,
which is truly scandalous because most poets,
except for Isaiah,
for instance,
we use a piece of port.
Okay prof,
but he's a prophet,
a piece I profit of peace with a vision of peace.
Dante really has an erratic,
erratic vision.
Uh,
most poets write about victories,
but wars about our MREs truces uh,
you know,
epic,
the epic.
So,
uh,
in England or in Italy,
it's all about the clashes of armies,
et Cetera,
not dentist.
So that's really the,
the direct answer I can give to your question.
But then you raise another issue,
which I find a little bit,
I would not want to go there,
but I owe it to,
to give her answer said,
well,
what about the peaceful language of Francis?
And that seems to be such a great idea because heresy and schisms in the
question,
the relationship between Christians and Muslims has always been one of wars.
So,
or heresy and war,
skis and war.
So we can say,
uh,
that Dante seems to be so radical.
It renouncing Warren says,
look,
it's possible to harmonize relationship or at least,
uh,
confront our differences in a book with using a piece language.
Okay.
That's however
things that are not as simple as that.
And that's why I only mentioned it,
but I will not go into that.
We haven't got time for that.
It's really a thought,
a little developing.
I must admit,
the Hennessy is a question of language.
It's not just a question of wars.
So there are wars that go on in language and therefore the re propose the very
differences.
And,
uh,
um,
a stubborn divisions of understanding that qualify and describe both the schisms
in the Harris's,
so to say,
peaceful language.
Uh,
it,
it sounds also like a good,
another way of another route in to potential the center and tragedy as you see.
But I'm not going to go any more than then give you as a,
as a kind of a suspicion that I have about,
uh,
my own claim that Dante is a piece,
a piece part.
We will talk to you about the Crusades next time.
And maybe I'm a,
I have time for another question maybe,
and they're very short answer anybody.
Oh,
see you next time.